one of the chapters in your book or one
of the sections i should say of
clearance and copyright everything you
need to know for film and television
is entitled to ask or not to ask
that is the question so what
would that entail what is a filmmaker
asking is they are they asking a
copyright holder for permission yeah and
i think this again is
is one of those a misconception people
have that if they do ask
they can't fear you something or if they
get a quote for something it affects
whether or not they can use something
under the under the fair use doctrine
and it really doesn't i think from a
risk perspective which i'll explain a
little bit it can
but from a legal perspective if you're
going to go out to the copyright holder
and ask for a license fee
and or ask for how much it would cost to
license something and they come back and
it's an exorbitant amount and you can't
afford it
you still can fair use that material it
doesn't affect the fair use argument at
all
what it does do though is it puts you on
the radar
for that license holder and then they'll
follow up with you and say hey are you
going to license that from us you know
we sent you that quote
and then you have to have sort of an
awkward conversation of no we're
actually using under fair use now and
they say no it's not fair to you it's
absolutely not fair use you have to
license it from us
and then they come to us and they say
well what should we do and so it kind of
it can create
a little bit of an uncomfortable
situation which i think all it really is
it's not a legal factor um and also can
create a little bit more in legal fees
because then you're
all of a sudden paying us or someone
else to negotiate with these guys
and sometimes in order to avoid a
dispute or to
to keep a good relationship you will
license something and maybe for a lesser
fee saying this really is fair use but
we're happy to license it from you
but we're not going to pay you what you
asked as you enter into that negotiation
so you know to ask or not to ask us a
question we get a lot
and typically i'll say you know you
shouldn't ask and it's not because we're
trying to hide anything
but it's because the person who's
licensing the footage to you or whatever
it is doesn't want to have that
conversation
it's not in their best interest and in
order to
elevate it up to the lawyers who would
be making the decision on whether or not
it's fair use
isn't really worth anybody's time do you
know what i mean so
i usually say don't ask unless there is
a reason to ask you know maybe there's a
relationship there
maybe you're you're delivering a film to
paramount and you want to use a film
from
use a clip from a film that also is
owned by paramount
then you probably should ask and have
that discussion but um
typically if it's just a run-of-the-mill
i want to use this news clip in my
documentary and it's clearly fair use
i would not go and ask for a license if
you know you're not going to license it
i also like to have insurance in place
before you go asking
it just makes everything more
comfortable and if the
price is very high we talk about
to the filmmakers about different ways
of
sort of excusing oneself from the
conversation for as long as possible
without
waving the fair use flag
it's because especially the studios
and the networks the person that
you talk to as a filmmaker has
as his or her sole job licensing clips
and their whole compensation their value
to the company
is how much money did you bring in
licensing clips so
they just will you know the hairs on the
back of their neck will stand up when
you start talking about fair use well
let's say i'm a documentary filmmaker
and i'm making
a film about let's say activism in the
60s and i want to use a clip from a folk
singer and this folk singer is still
alive let's say
would i just reach out to their personal
website
and send a nice email but already have
this eno insurance policy in place
and just play nice first yeah well you
may but you also may not
because you know my viewpoint and maybe
i'm being lazy about it but it's like
who wants to have that conversation if
you don't really have an intent to
license
it's sort of a waste of every time in a
sense it could be considered kind of
rude like why are you calling me if
you're not planning on licensing this
for me
so unless you know michael's example is
a perfect example where there
was a negotiation there they had already
brought maybe even agreed on some terms
then it makes sense from a business
standpoint
to continue that discussion and to let
them know
but you just reach out to the folk
singer when you really have no intention
of actually licensing it
i think is is counterproductive you know
it's just not it's not necessary and
it's kind of a waste of everybody's time
and in this case since i already
mentioned what the film was about
the uh one of the producers they want to
maintain a relationship
so it's right it makes sense
to call and have a courtesy call say you
know we got turned down
we worked on the film to make sure
everything came within fair use
they have insurance but i certainly
wanted you to know about it
and they uh they asked to see the film
it's it's fine
yeah you know and the opposite happens
as well where somebody does have an
intention to license
most or all of what's in their film and
then they try to license certain things
and the license doesn't work out for
some reason you know some
say they won't license in perpetuity and
they have to and the producer is under
an obligation to get all licenses in
perpetuity
so then you have the discussion i'm
dealing with this right now where i have
a client who's wanted to license
everything
um one entity has come back and said we
can't give you a license in perpetuity
we can give it to you for 30 years but
it was an exorbitant cost it was
something about three times what they
were paying for other archival material
that was similar
and so she said how should i respond i
said get back to them and say you know
we can't license it that amount we're
happy to license it if you could meet
our hundred dollars a second rate that
we're doing with everybody else
and if not we're gonna have to pass on
the license and so we're dealing with
that now but that was kind of the
converse of what we were talking about
before where they really did intend to
license everything and then they're just
running into hurdles
and if they can license it great if not
we're gonna use it under fair use
curious about it but it's interesting
the way you phrase that
they say we'll just have to pass on the
license as opposed to
we're going to use it anyway right for
you you know
it's all it's wonderfully nice a lot of
um
uh and i think it's more than just plain
nice it's a consideration
for two things one is they do own the
copyright
make a lot of money and two very
important
the person you're talking to at a studio
has this very
narrow job of maximizing income from
licensing clips
and and what you're basically doing is
is
a threat to the job certainly if it was
very widespread
this person would not be able to bring
in as much money
to the studio therefore they wouldn't be
making as much you know it's a really
very uh i i
and this goes for everything in life
every negotiation you ever have
you want to understand the other
person's position
they're not being jerks they just have
this very narrow
eight hour a day five days a week job
that they're doing
and they're not bad people they just
have very narrow limits very narrow
authority
they have a rate card and their job is
to get that rate
on every clip that's used of any
material from that studio
that's their job that was my next
question was the tone
of all the correspondence because so
many people get excited when they see
oh that's my whatever and you know and
then as you said playing nice so the
tone should always be
non-accusatory uh for most of the
exchange at some point
we're not litigators and very often
you know a lawyer will call very
bombastically and if you've got them
upset client i don't blame them for
being upset you know
you have to understand where they're
coming from
and that makes it easy to solve the
problem yeah it does and i also
you know that's our our philosophy and
the way we work in this office is that
we are collegial and i think it makes
our jobs
a lot easier we represent copyright
holders so we're not looking to screw
anybody over or get something that's not
ours or you know anything like that
and so when we get that angry call we do
understand and it's not you know as i
said for playing nice it's not playing
we really
are nice because we certainly understand
and
um and that's what makes it makes our
job easier and makes it much easier to
come to a resolution people because we
don't call them and say screw you it's
fair use
and you know sue us we really after we
get that call we respond
collegially with an educated response of
we understand you're upset but this is
the law that we've based our opinion on
and oftentimes michael likes to throw in
a copy of the book and throw in the copy
of the 150 page article that he wrote
and say you know
we didn't just willy-nilly say fair use
on this like we really
have bases on on education and the study
of the law and a deep understanding of
this area
you